right when it gets nice outside but I
welcome back to another installment of
PI data and Arbor I want to say that
looking at the registrants or members of
our group we have now just surpassed 700
people which is fantastic in less than a
year right I hopefully continue to
continue in continuing to grow more
I'd like to obviously thank everybody
involved in sponsoring the event
so obviously num focus we're sponsoring
that the poetic group itself TD
Ameritrade for offering up this
fantastic space as well as Midas for the
food that you're consuming so whatever
you see them I always tell them that you
know we're we're having such great
attendance as well as talks for people
that are new here remember that there
are a couple of emergency exits as one
right behind this white board over here
as well as just outside the door to the
right okay if so in case of emergency
take the stairs
we're always continuing continually
soliciting for feedback as well as for
speakers so if you know somebody who
knows somebody please reach out and help
us make those contacts and everything
that we do here is tracked on our github
page
so hopefully Katie would share some of
those valuable slides afterwards and you
can find it there or on the Associated
website and just like before unless your
your questions are quick please try to
keep them until the end and also
remember that you're in a world space so
take care of it
get rid of the any garbage that you have
left over there are garbage cans near
the where the food is I like to read our
pioneer code of conduct so I suppose you
for people who are new Partida is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meet
up events be kind to others do not
insult or put-down other attendee
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meet up
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers overall thank you for helping
making this a welcoming and friendly
environment for everybody so with that
I'd like to do our icebreaker so for
this month our icebreaker is because
there's a bit of a Midwest contingency
today I'd like you to turn to either
person to your left or to your right
introduce yourselves and tell them
whether you prefer pop or soda or
neither neither either either okay so go
ahead introduce yourself
this month in data science so I'd like
to highlight sci-fi it is coming up in
Austin Texas
July 9th to 15th and I believe today is
a last status to submit your abstract to
give a talk or presentation but
otherwise go and sign up and attend I
will be attending for the first time I
know Katie's a veteran at this and you
might want to ask her what her thoughts
are and also TD Ameritrade is hiring so
please reach out to Logan all stirred up
up here his team is hiring a has a
couple of open wrecks for a data science
position so and next month we have
another great speaker Holden Corral will
be talking about big data with Apache
spark and that's on March 13th
please sign up we're about half full
right now but I'm sure that's gonna fill
up quickly and then without further ado
I have a a sort of a co-host today so
I'd like to introduce dr. Patricia
Schuster you want to come up so dr.
Schuster is from the University of
Michigan and is the reason why we have
our guests today and I'll let you
introduce our speaker today professor
Catherine who's now at the University of
Illinois so I knew Katie when we were at
UC Berkeley together I was a grad
student and she was a postdoc so she is
very well known in nuclear engineering
for her work in fuel cycles but she's
also well known in scientific community
and data sight at data science for her
work in open source and reproducible
code development so we're happy to have
her here this week she's speaking
tonight at hi data and tomorrow she'll
be in the nuclear engineering department
at 4 p.m. in Cooley building if you're
interested to hear about her work in
fuel cycles so please help me welcome
her thank you thank you thank you so
much for being here thank you Sean and
Patricia for having me and Ameritrade in
general and I'm focused I'm Titus and
you know we have some really amazing
people like Charlie here who's also been
part of my little visit so thanks
everyone for being so welcoming and
lovely so I'm going to talk today about
my perspective
on best practices from the context of
like a scientific computing perspective
I hope that's interesting to you guys
how many of you have a science degree
yeah exactly right you're all your
little hearts true scientists how many
of you would describe what you're doing
right now as science yeah so some very
large percentage so that's awesome and
it's exactly what I expected in a
university town full of brilliant people
so I'm pretty excited hopefully this is
helpful to you I know a lot of you are
really well-informed about scientific
computing even reproducibility open
source Python etc but I would just say
that on some of the things that I've
come across I've actually been sort of
interesting among among the among the
dust there are some gems so I'll be
talking about doing our best as
scientists all right
so um Patricia mentioned this so I've
been a lot of places I was at the
University of Chicago and the University
of Wisconsin and I was at California
Berkeley and now I'm in Illinois I'm
really involved in the American nuclear
society I've written some piece of code
like Moltres and cyclists and perc and
pine and I Ryan research group that's
related to advanced reactors and fuel
cycles and I'm affiliated with the
National Center for supercomputing
applications and I used to work for the
Berkeley Institute for data science I'm
not going to talk about any of those
things I think I'm primarily going to
talk about my experience in mostly the
open source scientific computing
universe right and my experience with
that has been with Syfy so Shawn just
mentioned I'm super glad that he did the
scientific Python conference in Austin
which is my favorite place it's like
going home not just because I'm from
Texas but also because it's full of
really amazing scientific computing
folks who've written all of the packages
that you rely on almost all the time
they've written numpy and they're
hanging out there they wrote ipython and
Jupiter I know you guys had few great
Jupiter talks over the course this year
so you're really on board with that and
I think if you're interested in those
kinds of things you're gonna find the
authors of all those packages at side-by
and in fact one of the best parts of
sci-fi is not at the conference but the
Sprint's afterwards so you can stick
around for a few days
a type I continue to enjoy the great
state of Texas and contribute to open
source projects during the sprints so
there's two days of Sprint's at the end
of the conference where those developers
of numpy and others like Syfy packages
map out live panda is like you got
Jupiter folks you've got a whole fleet
of people doing all kinds of really cool
stuff
numbah tasks all those guys are at Syfy
and they want your help so guys and
girls guys in people people organization
that I'm super involved in that's called
the hacker within there's like an
organization that I helped to found when
I was a graduate student and it's it's
dedicated to graduate students finding
the hacker within themselves they may be
learning to be a physicist or a
biologist but they're gonna have to be a
hacker to get that PhD so they got
together and sort of like there's a lot
of peer learning and so a lot of the
lessons that I'll talk about in this
talk come from that really fun group I
also software carpentry and data
carpentry now called the carpenter ease
I haven't updated my slide to their new
logo which is like a cool wrench thing
how many of you have heard of software
country or data carpentry yeah of course
right it's like so software carpentry
data carpentry are great they are for
educating scientists about how to use
computers properly it is an extremely
important organization I thankfully was
helpful like in the initial stages of
that organization and it really changed
me as a scientist so I really hope you
guys get involved I'll also talk a
little bit about some of the lessons
that I've learned from being an editor
at jaws which is the journal for open
source software we're pretty new um well
I'll talk about sort of what that means
but it's basically a journal where
people review your software think about
it it's pretty great I'll talk about
some of the lessons learned from writing
a book with my friend Anthony ASCO pat's
who's an amazing person and book called
the practice of reproducible research
which I wrote with some of my colleagues
at this Berkeley Institute for data
science that I mentioned so this is the
stuff that I'll be talking about not all
the other stuff about my real career
this is my fun part all right but I will
briefly just tell you what nuclear
engineering is
so I will just say like since many of
you are gonna say to yourselves well I
wish we were talking about a little bit
of science I will say the science that I
do is on fission which is when a neutron
strikes an atomic nucleus and that
atomic nucleus gets very excited it's
got an extra Neutron and it splits apart
in its thrill and it's got a little
extra heat that it kicks out as well as
a few neutrons usually two or three and
we use those neutrons to then hit more
atomic nuclei to get what's called a
chain reaction all right and it's not
just a Keanu Reeves movie it is driving
nuclear reactors which heat up some
water
but then heat up other totally clean
untouched water that water typically
spins a turbine that turbine spins a
magnet inside a coil of lot of wire
which is also known as like a power
generator and it powers in this case it
appears to be Seattle okay so that's
nuclear engineering you now understand
more engineering and most of the public
so I don't know why this is a tiny this
is supposed to be this beautiful big
picture so this is a great beautiful
wind simulation that it's done like
entirely on an open source stack and I'm
just going to use it as the background
for the following slide so that you can
enjoy it I'm not responsible for it
this is from the indole school net but
it's a so wind simulator and if you all
share this link to my slides at the end
so you can go and play with it because
it's super cool
it's got a lot of layers this is the
pretty layer Oh see now it's like zoom
is something about HDMI is freaking out
all right
so what am I talking about so science
can do a whole lot much more than we can
imagine right we put a car into space a
few weeks ago okay that's pretty wild
but recently as recently as 1895 really
well educated people thought that even
just flying machines at all we're
impossible 1895 1895 that is not that
long ago you know there are like hundred
and fifteen year old still
you know and they just you know they
were just barely they were thoughts in
their parents minds in 1895 they's like
it's not that long ago so we can really
make some amazing innovation in science
but scientists really relied on
criticism and organized skepticism so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about how
you can build that into your software as
a scientist ultimately this is all for a
purpose science we care about typically
because science drives things in our
world
it puts cars into space right but it
also changes our public health scenario
changes our --power scenario it makes
our air either clean or not clean all of
these things are very very important and
so we need really evidence-based
conclusions for these kinds of things
and so science itself is the like sort
of bulwark of all of this and it's
supposed to build an organized knowledge
and test explanations about the universe
it's supposed to do so systematically
and objectively and transparently and
reproducibly and otherwise you really
just can't call it science right and
science ultimately it relies on peer
review right you have to be able to look
at each other's work and say is this
true and skepticism the inherent belief
that even though they are your friends
your colleagues might be making mistakes
transparency you need to be able to
share all of that information so other
people build on it attribution and
accountability collaboration impact
since the sixth century BCE the entire
domain of science has been perfecting
these tenants and is my opinion that's
open-source software is now superior at
all of them okay so let's talk about it
how why what science gonna do about it I
think so I apologize for you who saw my
PyCon talk because there are some
borrowed slides here and there but bear
with me there are new slides in this
time that weren't in that talk so don't
worry my opinion computer should help
with efficiency reducing human error
automating the mundane
simplifying the complex and accelerating
research but scientists aren't very good
at them this is why open source is
getting better at it is that there are
these tools that can help us accelerate
what we're doing but scientists are
trying to be scientists most scientists
have not taken programming classes
particularly scientists my age or older
I never took a programming class my
entire day is programming writing about
programming reviewing code teaching
programming and discussing some of the
simulation results like it's all about
the software so um what are we gonna do
this is great quote by Victoria Stodden
who is a fabulous professor at the
University of Illinois and she says this
very succinctly and so I would just say
that this is a great thing to sort of
think about that computational science
is a special case of scientific research
where it should be easy to replicate the
results it should be nothing but sharing
the files so interested in this sort of
general feeling about the need for
reproducibility in science the tools
that we have at our disposal and
generally speaking the total ineptness
of scientists because we were not
trained a lot of amazing people and
myself wrote this great paper best
practices for scientific computing so
I'll go through some of the lessons we
give ten sort of 10 ish lessons
the first one is write programs for
people not computers all these lessons
are supposed to help scientists make
their code reproducible well I would
writing programs for people that
computers help any ideas it's gonna be
really interactive the ability of this
code a program she now requires readers
to hold more than a handful of facts in
memory at once because people don't read
and interpret large things well we read
about a paragraph at a time
think about why are paragraphs even in
text why do we have paragraphs yeah it's
because we can't hold more than that in
our minds at a single moment we should
try to make names consistent distinctive
and meaningful and generally have good
clogs coding style so for this means use
style guides
and make meaningful names and you know
you shouldn't have functions that are
exceptionally long your functions should
be like a paragraph in length you should
let the computer do their work so Greg
Wilson who of course is the first author
of this paper and a fabulous human and
founder software carpentry and all these
things
his favorite analogy is that you're
great at going out to the movies you're
great at thinking creatively and walking
through the park and the computer is not
not great at these things but it's great
at chugging the same calculation over
and over again with minor parametric
changes it's great it's sorting your
files for you it's great at globbing
various strings together but you your
time is better spent how did the movies
with your sweetie okay so make the
computer do repetitive tasks save recent
commands in a file for use use a build
tool to automate workflows it is raging
hot in here and I would just say that
everyone's gonna need to stay alert so
to help you guys stay alert I'm going to
introduce various little interactive
activities one of them is what is your
favorite build tool you have ten seconds
turn to your friend tell them don't
waste your energy don't waste it all
right this sounds like great I heard I
heard make I heard bundler I heard
various scripts anyone else snake make
very good waft all right Wow I'll look
into it
so yeah tools like help to automate your
workflows the classic is make you might
you might configure your make files with
like auto con funada make or like if you
don't hate yourself you might not who
knows
make your no incremental changes so one
of the things that it science so this
paper in general relies on a whole bunch
of like meta analyses of various suffer
experiences so like they studied
software engineers they studied
scientific computing folks and one of
the things that was found to be the most
influential on keeping bugs out of the
code was making tiny changes rather than
very large changes so that was pretty
easy small commits that's your that's
your that's your undo button that's the
size of your undo button obviously use a
version control system anyone here not
using a version control system like git
or mercurial or SVN or CVS or even
really really really ancient ones um if
you're not using one like let's just
let's just chat afterward it's gonna be
great like if you know this is nothing
to be afraid of git has the most hideous
like non-intuitive commands we're gonna
get through it together it's true it's
gonna be fun yeah it tires me after if
you're not because it's gonna change
your life for him okay don't Peters but
I'll just say that all jokes aside
scientists don't use version control
systems they're afraid it's too it's too
hard most scientific pis are not willing
they have 17 folders a final final final
final final draft reviewed by so-and-so
it's just not gonna work so don't repeat
yourself everyone knows this like this
is like a refrain
programming is the drive principle
modular eyes could reuse your code
instead of rewriting it every piece of
data needs a single op to thaw rotative
representation in the system these rules
feel really obvious to people who have
seen them before and they are not
obvious at all
to people who haven't and so like as
scientists you sort of have to step back
and share with your colleagues these
kinds of rules that say you know it is
easier to introduce a bug if you are
copying and pasting it all over your
code then when you fix it once where are
you gonna have to fix it all over your
code so unfortunately like you're gonna
miss it once or twice so if you have it
in just one place then a bug can only
exist in one place it won't exist all
over the universe and so this is like a
key a key piece of knowledge okay plan
for mistakes scientific code typically
doesn't defend against user error like
user errors just a thing that like when
you run it you deal with it at that
moment I would say that like good
scientific code does it adds assertions
for programs to check their operation it
does unit testing you don't have to
invent your own unit testing framework
and in fact it's a bad idea use an
off-the-shelf unit testing framework for
whatever programming language you use
jargon sleepy again turn your friends
ten seconds what's your favorite unit
testing framework and if you don't know
what a unit testing framework is explain
it to or like vice-versa have your buddy
explain it to you go
that's a great question it's hard to
know what the answer is but if you have
small enough functions yes like I may be
a simpleton it could be the case that
that only works okay okay okay all right
don't waste your energy
you guys are producing 60 watts of peace
don't get too excited
so I had a great question actually one
of the best questions ever actually just
came up so should you use test-driven
development for your scientific software
test-driven development is where you
write the test that says hey this is
exactly what I expect this function to
do for various interpretations of its
parameters it should throw an error if I
give it strings it should average them
if I give it a list of numbers it should
throw a not implemented type if I throw
it a list of complex numbers something
like that should you do it for science
in science you don't usually know the
answer before you start programming but
for small enough functions you should so
if your code is written with small
functions then you should know the
answer for how each of those small
functions behave you may not know how
the clock works you should know how all
the gears work that make sense
sweetie so you may not have good
test-driven development on the
integration test side or like but you
should have it on the unit test safe
did anyone have any favorite test
reminds PI test used to be nose test
when it's no longer supported anyone
else J Annette yeah
all right cool so we'll talk about our
in a minute but there's some problems
there
uh premature optimization is a problem
we're scientists it's very hard to
approach a problem and not try to do it
as well as possible immediately we get
all everything we've been trained to do
you would probably agree it's to always
win and always get the right answer
better than everyone else in the class
every time it's actually better to try
to just do the stupid simple thing
do a little agile work and then fix it
up and make it better later because
writing code in the highest level
language possible like Python is going
to save you time not trying to perfect
it the first time it's gonna save you
time and actually using a profiler to
identify any kind of memory bottlenecks
it's gonna work better after you've
written the code not before because you
can't run the profile if you do it
before huh snake Vince that's right
so profilers lots of great profilers
Python let's make this is read for
visualizing it come krav exists if
you're not working in Python you might
use Val grind and you'll get used to the
output eventually cool you should
document things for design and code
purpose but not mechanics what I mean by
that so one of the things we found was
the documentation is really unhelpful we
didn't find this actually other reason
this is like kind of a meta paper where
we read a whole bunch of papers to
determine what the right answers were
and number of researchers have
discovered that documentation that
describes how a templated class is
implemented like or not these are not
very helpful for the user of those
templates as much help it's much more
helpful to say like what that thing is
supposed to do and how you use it and
like what the concept is so interfaces
and reasons not how it was implemented
documentation isn't the place for
describing implementation first of all
if you change the implementation now you
also have to change the documentation oh
you should refactor code in preference
to explaining how it works so when you
change code you should make sure it's
becomes more clear as you do so and you
should try to embed the documentation
for a piece of software in that software
so of course you should be using Docs
strings in Python you should be using
like well formatted Docs agenda your C++
etc etc all right that helps you make an
automated
documentation website all right
collaborate review code before you Marg
it use pair programming when bringing
someone new up to speed and tackling
particularly risky problems using issue
tracking tool this feels really
reasonable for people who are currently
working in the software industry it
might be hard for scientists so this is
really important I think for today's
software industry and they would never
think of not reviewing code before
merging to like to you know to master
probably probably I hope you guys don't
do that there's like websites out there
relying on you're not doing that but in
science is actually really hard to get
people to volunteer their time to review
each other's work and this is where we
really start to see open-source succeed
where academic science is failing a peer
review it should be the case that if
your scientific code is out there in the
world and your colleagues and at other
institutions are interested in what
you're up to you know there should be
some incentive for them to look at what
you're doing and check that it's right
just like they would a peer-reviewed
article they spend some time and look
closely at it you know but it's really
hard to incentivize that with suffer
there are a number of things in the way
different software stacks different
capabilities ultimately there's there's
no prize at the end even if you're at a
National Lab and you're all sort of
working together on a team it's
different than in academia like where
you're sort of the little cutthroat it's
still very hard to incentivize things
like pair programming and peer review
for code and so this is one of the
places where you have to tell scientists
that this is the right thing to do for
Less buggy software and this will create
less buggy software but it's very hard
it's very hard to convince yeah that's a
great question do you make somebody a
coder co-author if they simply did a
cobra code review and I'd say that's
gonna vary by research group and my
research group they end up in the
acknowledged
unless they contributed to the software
like in a direct fashion but that may
change over time if there are
significant so right now the only people
who do reviews typically are the people
involved and those pieces of software so
like my research group is pretty tight
per software project but I think it's a
really good idea to think about how
people are acknowledged and that would
be a great incentive for people to do
code reviews because then they could
conceivably end up as a co-author
particularly if they have substantive
review comments and you do have
substantive review comments you're
effectively not there yes true true so
yeah if you're using your fork you're
and you've committed to that fork like
you're an author he was saying like
because of the way pull requests work
whether or not I ever accept the pull
request for certain licenses if you make
commits to your fork
I never even have to pull the pull
request for you to be an author of that
code and in fact you are in a sense you
are an author of that secondary code and
I actually do recommend very permissive
licenses like that for academia so I use
BSD 3 for all my software which allows
people to do exactly that and all they
have to do is attribute me when they
attribute themselves to their you know
new version of the code yeah incentives
are tricky in academia very tricky
indeed sorry I want to watch the time so
that I don't like waste you guys's lives
okay so I'm gonna move on from that best
practices in scientific computing paper
and I'm just gonna sort of a talk a
little bit about some of the things that
I like to tell scientists that sort of
came out of this book that I hope
co-wrote with my friend Anthony scope at
who is
more famous for his work on a text
editor called EXO and shell called conch
than he is for his really great work in
nuclear engineering just because he's so
good at this other stuff now because
because he's just a really amazing
all-around human I'd say that all this
skepticism and stuff really falls into
what you need to do to get started so I
like to tell people there's sort of a
good better best good pencil and paper
better spreadsheet we have to tell
scientists it's best to use like a
standardized data format like a database
your management system in lots of
scientific domains there are very
specific data formats that people use if
you're in astro you might use fits files
and nuclear use these evaluated nuclear
data sets etc but you should manage them
in a real DB okay so you guys know that
you should backup files with version
control now with hope or emails to
yourself so one of the things I like to
tell my scientific colleagues is
actually there's this so some people are
very successful at managing all of their
files by just emailing themselves every
night before they go home
that those files so that like if their
computer ever dies it's not a problem
but obviously version control managing
changes there's naming conventions
there's clever naming conventions and
then there's local version control
clever naming conventions can get you
pretty far actually so keep that in mind
but obviously this is how version
control works I'm gonna skip a couple of
these because I think you guys know some
of them instead of doing analysis with
spreadsheets or some sort of commercial
off-the-shelf package you should
probably use open source libraries
because they can be debugged because
even Mathematica and MATLAB have bugs
right if I if you don't believe that
think hard about who you think works in
MATLAB all right check out mine this is
a great example for engineers a
scientist for like what it looks like to
sort of build a whole open source stack
in science right you know we should do
scripted batch editing so I don't know
what everyone's
with scripting languages for like
cleaning data cleaning data is a huge
part of science as well as like data
science I don't mean to put that in
quotes but like this whole large field
that you guys are like changing the
world with so I don't know what you use
but I use a lot of said NOC and grep but
that's because I'm old so I like bash
and Python as well but actually my first
programming language was Perl
so I write write only code sometimes
yeah uh so for executing workflows you
could retie up a series of commands over
and over again you could put them all in
a bash script and run that every time or
you could use like a make file system
which checks whether or not you even
really need to run that command before
it then tries to run it right so that's
the whole purpose of things like make is
to avoid unnecessary typing as well as
unnecessary CPU usage so make is gonna
keep you from using CPU hours that you
don't need on tasks that have already
been completed for which all the
dependencies have remained the same
since the last time you did it so make
auto kompot it makes you make etc so I'm
a very big fan of C make that like dig
it auto caponata make was because one
day after years of auto coffin auto make
I discovered C make and I was like wow
you can write configuration files in
English ah that's great so data
structures this is one of the key things
that I think I struggle with actually is
that Professor my students are really
amazing people but they want to put
everything in a list everything they
want to put pede dictionaries in like
complicated sets of lists that are named
with different variable names which
should be the key in a dictionary and
it's obvious to me to look at it and I
say ok clearly this should be a
dictionary with all of those variable
names those should be the keys in that
Python dictionary and it just isn't it
isn't really very intuitive for someone
who hasn't seen the flexibility of a lot
of these data structures and so using
the right data structure for the thing
that you're doing that is half the
battle because iterating over a key
dictionary like it's going to be a lot
easier than it
reading over 45 very variably named
lists I like to tell nuclear engineers
this because it's distressing to know
that in Fortran they may also be using
like vectors rather than arrays in C++
there's maps vectors decks etc obviously
I think if I die and the power is in
dictionaries and umpire arrays but it's
going to depend on your language let's
skip over a few of these things sorry
I'm supposed to be able to skip some of
these but I'll just say API designed
small testable functions we talked about
this a little bit a lot of people write
a lot of single blocks of procedural
code it's not great code proliferation
is bug proliferation I like to tell
people variable naming is one of the
most important things so obviously the
biggest perk of being a programmer is
you get to name something every few
minutes but you should do it properly
right good fine but better right you
should create a class that holds points
if you're gonna hold a point type object
don't create three variables called x
y&z and expect that everyone agrees that
it's car-like Cartesian coordinates I
said draw file IO a lot of general
science software is gonna have Auto
hard-coded variables that only work on
someone's machine if there's stepped up
they're gonna have one plain text input
file and that's gonna be sort of parsed
line by line by their own homemade
string parser obviously the better is
some sort of pile parsing library or art
parse something like that you're gonna
have some input database instead for
example you could use real like
languages that are intended for this
kind of metadata like XML which has like
relaxed grammar structures available or
JSON or whatever so I'd say just like
don't do the hard-coded variables thing
I'm gonna skip a couple of these things
these are I'll just say like in each of
these chapters sections there's like
various pieces like different scientists
are gonna use different pieces better
than others obviously for error
detection you want to have a unit test
suite and instead of just rereading the
code to diagnose errors you should use a
linter and a
bugger and a profiler so we've sort of
covered some of these things but I'll
say that like if you want to look over
these I don't wanna like keep you guys
so this is like raging hot but I'll just
say there are a lot of tools listed in
this talk for some of these things so
give it a look
so for collaborating obviously I I think
that github is the answer
I say obviously maybe some of you were
in a bit bucket what's up yeah so yeah
well totally fits in a lot of places so
you can use that instead of X XML in a
lot of places but you're gonna use it at
the top of a lot of files for various
other purposes so I've actually seen a
lot of very clever use of Hamel so on
the back end of like this website for
example you could sorry this this
presentation is a website that's Randall
rendered like with reveal Jas and you
can actually use markdown to serve up
some of these slides and like those
markdown files can't have um only have
headers to help so it's in there all
over the place if you're doing things
right but I would say that like anywhere
you would previously see something like
an XML you might you might think about
it yeah malaria JSON or something like
yeah that's a great question right peer
review for code etc I want to move on to
Joss though because it's my friend oh I
should move on to this briefly okay
sorry I've got so many projects you guys
okay I know it's so hot but just like
just brace yourselves I was part of this
really cool experience at Berkeley where
and when Deakin here was part of it to
kind of where like there are all these
people who are doing science and like
what kind of vaguely be called data
science within their sciences and we all
sat together in a room like this was
exactly these same chairs it was a
really hip space and it it actually sort
of bent it like sort of brought up a
bunch of questions around what the
proper way to actually do reproducible
research is and we basically got it
together a whole bunch of scientists who
are trying really hard to be
reproducible and we said okay what are
you doing
and we had like a workshop we had
everyone write a flowchart of like where
their data comes from and where it goes
and what script runs it I'm sorry that's
mine don't talk too much
alarm oh what script runs it and like
who deals with it and who does the
analysis and where does the plot come
from and we put all these key studies
together into a book and like I had the
pleasure of reading through all of them
and pulling out lessons learned right so
that was my job as part of this book and
it was one of these experiences where I
felt like a lot of pain like up those
authors really felt connected to the
people who written these things everyone
wrote a few pages on like how their
workflow worked that it says that like
came together with this that this this
diagram some of the other so the editors
of this diagram are sorry that this book
are just in kids has fought my MMO glue
and you know Turek Ben Warwick helped a
whole heck of a lot and there are a lot
of chapter authors in case study authors
but I'll just say this is what these
workflows look like some of them were
really complicated everyone was given
like a lot of freedom some of them had
data input and data output and theory
and not theory and exploration some of
them had like real sections some of them
didn't and this is sort of what that
workshop looked like it was invitation
only so we only invited the people we
thought we're trying really hard some of
them made insane flow charts like this
like this is after editing this is like
this is the things that they hold in
their head to keep their workflow
working in science and we asked like
what why do you try what hurts what kind
of recommendations would you give
someone trying what you're doing and
then I did a little data analysis on on
the text itself to see like what exactly
they really were doing and we identified
some needs so I just say most people did
it so that they could collaborate better
and focused on focus on science if their
code is definitely gonna work they can
focus a little better on science and a
lot of people said that they wanted
verifiability and extensibility so that
graduate students working with them
could leave and it's not the end of the
world
and so they tried to make their code
reproducible but the things that hurt by
and large vast majority of people their
biggest problem with was with people and
varying skill sets almost everyone had a
large group of collaborators and no or
even small groups of collaborators had
this problem but it was never the case
that everyone had exactly the same
software stack like available to them
and so so and so wants to write the
paper in latex but you know this guy
would rather write it like in his like
nice overleaf experience so it's kind of
late but it's not but they want a
version good so they have to do this
whole thing and you know someone wants
to write in Python but this guy only
knows R is a huge problem for most
people
dependencies build systems and packaging
building things on computers is hard
having access to various Hardware made
things reproducible some people work on
it from our mission fMRI machines or
stellarator right do you have a
stellarator like University of Illinois
has one but it's really hard to
reproduce it's a science done on
something like that because there's only
a couple right do you have another Large
Hadron Collider right will you be
reproducing the work that's done there
so that's a hardware access problem
testing was hard like getting incentives
to do that publishing was hard data
versioning was hard all these things are
the things that were hard data
restrictions were mentioned by a couple
people mostly in the Medical Sciences
and in nuclear engineering my own field
where you can get arrested for sharing
too much right everyone said version
control open your data test everything
use open tools we've gone over these
things but all of those people agreed
with all the things that you and I have
just been discussing the recommendations
also included some kind of clever things
like if you can avoid depending on some
package avoid it because it's like
really hard to build new dependencies
into your software or at least package
their installation put it in a darker or
something host your code on github get
digital object identifiers for your data
in code we can talk about that more
later but I'll just say like there's
some like clever stuff here I'll let you
just read them I'm supposedly about
photographer
forty minutes so I have four more
minutes okay so I'm gonna skip these
outliers but I'll give you some data so
I looked over everyone's workflow this
instead like what tools are they
actually using github was the most
common Python was the most common
language everyone tried to use item
tried to use latex our was the second
most common language and lots of people
were using Jupiter but not as many as I
expected so we had about I don't know 30
case studies or something
so I expected a lot more of that and
yeah so language use like we had some
multiple language projects but it was
mostly Python and our people have kind
of abandoned C++ and Java for like
really reproducible software development
in science interestingly this is my most
favorite graph for this whole talk
Python users aren't pink people who use
both R and Python in a single package
are purple our users are blue on this
side here the people who are trying to
do their best half of them or so wrote
tests
slightly less than half here on the
other side everyone who didn't write any
tests so there's like 30 ish people
total they either Road tester didn't
write tests and there's about the same
number of Python users in both groups
but so many more are ER users in the no
test group we know why that is it's hard
to write tests in our there's only one
like widely used our testing framework
and no one uses it so there's a huge
problem and I'm worried about everyone
that uses our and we should all be
worried that's the best the conclusion
this graph Python users have like a
fleet of Python unit testing libraries
to choose from our users have just one
and no one uses it to my understanding
all right we'll skip forward and I'll
just say as a last sort of like cool
thing I work on this journal for open
source software this is a brilliant idea
of a wonderful person called Arvind
Smith used to work at github
now he's back doing science but
generally speaking there's a whole bunch
of cool people sorry I just skipped over
them all right yeah they are all the
coolest people in
world are on this okay not really all of
them but like a very remarkable set of
people are on this including Jake van
der Plaza car the Grom Tracy teal who's
now running the carpet trees so some
amazing people our editors of this
journal and it's on github and you we
now have two hundred and thirty two
accepted papers we've been around for
about a year and a half and the way that
it works is that you have some open
source project let's call it baskets and
you have a repository where you host
baskets and you and all your academic
collaborators are working on baskets and
yeah okay sometimes you produce a paper
that's related to baskets but like no
one can really cite baskets right you
could create as a note OID for it but it
doesn't go on your CV you could create a
DOI that like is a digital object
identifier for baskets but it doesn't
have any kind of academic merit no one's
ever said like we approve of baskets
right jaws does code review on baskets
so you submit baskets and a short
summary of what baskets is capable of -
jaws so you tell us where the github
repository is or bitbucket or whatever
and you send us a markdown file which is
usually in the repository ideally and we
check for a whole list of useful things
mostly the things that I've just listed
in this presentation does it have tests
is it documented can I build it on my
machine so the reviewers are asked to
take take a moment go build this
software go look at it review it run the
tests does it work
do we like it does it do the six things
that the markdown file says it does it's
a very fast review process but we
typically help most of these software
projects get some of those better
practices in and then there's like a
sizable thing that has been reviewed by
other academics who do scientific
software in your domain and it's it's
like a real paper because we're indexed
on Google Scholar now so take that and
we have a paper about our journal so you
can read all about just as of like a few
days ago so we reviewed the first year
so if you're interested in jaws or
submitting to
or reading about how jaws works or
taking down the whole model and telling
us what we're doing wrong let us know
super cool so that's why I really have
here so okay I should say a lot of these
thoughts came from my personal
experience but a lot of it is you know
from conversations with colleagues
across my whole universe in life so
thank you to them
so yeah I'll just end it here and you
can find the slides right there at this
link which it's just a URL thank you yes
yeah so this is like the beginning of
Plato's sort of yeah Plato it was posted
say like this sorry a stellarator is on
as a stellarator it's a type of toroidal
ah okay the current question is what is
a stellarator and the answer is it's a
toroidal fusion device but it's not like
a boring toroidal fusion device it's not
just a tokamak it has a weird twist in
it for some reason great question
other questions yes a lot of people
doing work either efficient or illusion
and tokamak was I think the first fusion
device I a lot of people in the
efficient of fusion world using open
source off some of them are sorry we
have a couple of nuclear engineers in
the audience and they are impact doing
so I do with all of my suffer with my
research group my PhD advisor who I
actually Oh most of my intellectual
ability at these days is paulo ph wilson
at the university wisconsin we're not
alone i would say that there's a like
small but growing population of people
who are trying to do nuclear there are a
couple things we're not allowed to share
like that you know a certain cross
section like probability information
about certain nuclear reactions we're
not allowed to share for example what's
up
excellent everything is fine
I'm fieldworks the moment it works
somebody wants to like have it under
security control because it works how do
you make something that was open-source
community through a censorship
I don't mmm I would make it if you could
make it be born open-source and slap an
open-source license on it and wait for
someone to complain that's my current
strategy shouldn't say that I need to I
would say though that you do have to be
careful and if you have a piece of code
that you must go through are sacct for
distribution a number of a number of
pieces of code like like serpent for
example like they typically try to send
this source to most the people that they
approve its an anokhin source model no
there is like no one has access to the
repository can you run the test
yes locally I'm not really like it's
this baton it's a tricky situation as a
community so for really like alright for
some of it I think we do have to rely on
the government's are sick program to vet
people and internally are sick should
probably have a gitlab instance maybe
someone should go work for are sick and
give them a get lab and sense just to
take it seems like an undergrad for a
summer it's not that hard just like
setting up all those codes on get lab
Oakridge has so a few different labs up
like labs have various Gil Evanston says
just for their lab so I don't has one
Oakridge has one and you can log in with
your Oakridge convential zero like idaho
credentials that's probably the answer
this is true so who you trust though in
nuclear I think what he's getting at is
you're totally right for most people's
application for nuclear who you trust is
determined by the government so we have
to actually let this this group called
our sake deal with it thank you so
there's so many more okay yeah a lot of
fantastic best principles not all the
scientists I work with are you missing
all his principles is definitely
incrementally I would start with version
control sounds brutal sounds brutal so
his question was lots of scientists
don't do this stuff you guys came here
knowing most of this stuff hopefully you
learned at least a couple of cool fun
buzz words that you're gonna go google
but yeah the real the real take away is
it like you're the foot soldiers on the
ground to encourage your colleagues to
do these things better and now you have
a few reasons you got a paper you can
show him but who what do you teach them
first I think that most scientists are
blown away by the capabilities of
version control as soon as they really
get like what the power is that they
don't have to have 70 folders called you
know run one run seven run ninety-two
like that's a real game-changer for a
lot of scientists and I think as soon as
it like they really get it I've seen
people particularly at software
carpentry workshops I've seen people
become just devotees that's why there
are so many software carpentry
instructors in my opinion is anyone here
in soft recovery researcher okay
yeah in my opinion I like a lot of
people becomes out there covered in a
circus because they're sitting in a boot
camp they realize oh god this is gonna
change everything and it's usually in
the version control part in my opinion
so there's something called I don't want
to I want to kill everyone but I could
talk about this for a while
there's a significant difference from
the scientific perspective between
replicability and reproducibility so
packaging your whole system and just
like preserving it in its state as a
complete virtual machine that is
replicability because you will run
exactly that code in exactly that way
and when reproducibility is a little
different
I think computational reproducibility is
kind of in between real like traditional
scientific reproducibility where you run
another experiment exactly like that
first experiment at a different lab
somewhere else and you have your own
beakers I don't know whatever wet lab
scientists do that's not my jam and then
replicability which is this like verge
control I'm sorry personal machine sort
of scenario so that's like way over here
in replicability and it's like you're
doing it exactly with exactly that
machine computational reproducibility
that I'm trying to get at personally is
this thing kind of in-between where
you're running same code maybe with new
parameters and you're testing the
conclusions based on the software that
they've written because you understand
the tools and software but it's this
virtual machine that's that's gonna
that's the kind of sorry the virtual
machine and that's the kind of thing
that it's just it's just rote repetition
that makes it so it does change things
for some people because then they can at
least send their software somewhere
without worrying about docker okay all
right maybe I don't know who's in
control I don't know when this has to
end
okay I think so yeah yeah so I think
software development in general it's
okay for something to be a little wrong
you know your goo is like a little
officer on color something like that or
like you
your data analysis is like a little
fuzzy in some angle but like you're
gonna get the same conclusion or some
science really need to get it all quite
right and so the testing part and really
like deep unit testing of all of your
assumptions I think is so much more
important than science I think you guys
can get away with a little less unit
testing frankly then scientists really
should be getting away with and the
actual the opposite is true I think you
guys are a ton of testing I say you guys
know I know not all of you were in like
this tech industry but like I would say
that like software development in an
industry does a lot more unit testing
than maybe they absolutely need to
whereas in science like we should be
doing vastly vastly more than we are now
cuz it's really that like testing of
your own assumptions and being able to
like extend a current piece of software
like I don't know how long a single
piece of software lives on at Facebook
but I don't think it's as long as for
example the Monte Carlo Neutron
transport code that nuclear engineers
have been relying on since the 70s to do
floating-point areas every impact
reproducibility or like for example just
science in general yeah I actually use
the decimals package pretty often in
cyan pile time so there's a there's a
sci-fi I think it's yeah there's a
decimals package which allows you like
explicit representation of decimals type
numbers rather than using the floating
it's like not very memory efficient but
do I want it to be memory efficient or
do I want it to be right typically I
want it to be right I got memory to
spare
I've really I love that question how
much does it do scientists not being
aware versus the tools not being tooled
up well enough for them I think it's
mostly awareness but I'll also say it
could have an easier user interface like
there should why are there 2 meanings of
the word checkout and why is it
different than the one that SVN used I
think that those things are a little
confusing for people but I would say
it's mostly awareness and to also kind
of go I don't want to abuse any
scientists but I'd go slightly further
and say scientists can be aware of a
thing without truly believing that it's
right like all humans we need a lot of
proof to believe that this is the thing
that we must do I think there's not as
much incentive as there could be even
for the things that we're where other
people are doing and probably are right
or maybe hard this is like a little slow
to admit which things are worth our time
so there's that problem there's sort of
a in your shot Thanks
with that I want to welcome everybody to
stick around a little bit longer but
also want to acknowledge again dr. Jeff
Shuster for having Cadia join us today
and can we give a round of applause
[Applause]